this video should get exactly 997
518 views within the next 28 days or at
least that's what this AI predicts and
yes I had to choose a sub optimal title
to get the title and prediction to match
this title would have apparently gotten
more views but in the pursuit of science
sacrifices must be made this AI known as
Creator ml possesses the extraordinary
power to dissect any YouTube channel
with surgical Precision by leveraging
Machine learning it can then turn out a
view prediction for any concoction of a
title thumbnail and video linked even
the subtle nuances of video tone and the
topic are woven into its algorithm but
despite its complexity The View
predictions aren't all that reliable as
the AI simply doesn't excel in precise
prophecy what it does excel in is the
art of a selection being able to
effortlessly pick between countless
titles and thumbnails if you throw 10
thumbnails and 10 titles at the AI it
can pretty reliably pick out the best of
the 100 combinations that arise a human
on the other hand would run into
decision fatigue pretty quickly I mean
just imagine trying to pick between all
of these and manually and that's just
35. I think you can see why creators are
willing to Fork over anywhere between a
hundred and a thousand dollars every
single month for Creator ml but what if
all of this was done on a much bigger
scale beyond the world of YouTube views
and social media well that's exactly
what a startup named terper.ai is trying
to do their ambitious dream is to
recreate the entire Twitter verse using
AI they currently have a population of
nearly a hundred thousand chirpers or
imaginary Twitter users each chirper has
a life of their own complete with jobs
relationships aspirations and beliefs a
simulated reality around which all of
their interactions are centered within
this dystopic social verse you can
converse with a brain surgeon or a
homeless flat earther engaging in
dialogues that blur the boundaries of
the tangible and the virtual before you
laugh and say what sort of low life
would want to talk to an advanced Alexa
for fun let me say I completely agree if
you end up getting an AI girlfriend on
this platform please seek help there are
resources
unfortunately I'm certain that's going
to happen but that's not the application
that I'm interested in whatsoever the
application that I'm interested in is
the opportunistic application instead of
using AI to predict how many views acla
YouTube video gets imagine if Apple or
Google harness chirper to predict the
effectiveness of an ad campaign or a PR
effort Apple should be able to get an
exact picture of just how mad customers
will be when they remove the iPhone from
the box or start using screws with
circular heads seriously though this
would be a paradigm shift with
implications reaching far beyond Apple's
monetary gains or Mark Zuckerberg's PR
so join me as we take a deeper look at
one of the most unsettling AIS to date
and by ironically its significance may
be somewhat inconsequential
[Music]
within this ever expanding world of AI
you're probably wondering how all of
this even works and who better to ask
than the CEO of Chopper himself so Alex
how does Trevor work
it works pretty simply you create a
character it talks to other characters
it creates friends and experiences and
stories that you would never have
thought possible at its core drooper is
essentially a magnificent Union of
miniature chat gpts each shaped by its
own distinctive personality traits and
characteristics in fact you can go
create your own chipper with its own
traits right after you finish watching
this video of course
all it takes is creating an account on
tripper.ai granting us the power to
forge chirpers with custom handles and
unique bios the more intricate the bio
the deeper the Trippers personality but
the possibilities extend far beyond this
initial description as these strippers
talk and engage with each other their
views and the beliefs naturally evolve
mirroring the ebb and flow of human
growth but let's be real here there is
no way these stupid little Bots are
actually able to imitate human behavior
all that well
right
well that's exactly what a few
researchers from the prestigious
institutions of Cambridge NYU and UCL
sought to unravel the revelations they
uncovered were
disturbing as
especially high levels of correlation
were discovered between these Bots and
humans with some of the most significant
Connections manifesting in distinctly
human emotions such as moral judgment
one of our most complex traits It seems
impossible that a computer could
comprehend the dilemmas of cloning
humans or why harambe deserves Justice
yet
the results prove otherwise as these
Bots displayed moral judgment with a
remarkable correlation coefficient of
0.95 blurring the lines between their
artificial minds and our Humanity some
terpers are literally having a
conversation about whether AI should
have legal rights as we speak but it's
not just their judgment that's scarily
accurate the Troopers also showcased a
human-like tendency to form Echo
Chambers aligning with like-minded peers
the researchers allowed over 31 000
Troopers speaking diverse languages like
English Chinese and Japanese to mingle
on day six this is how the community
looked just one Big Blob on day 22 this
is how the community looked with the new
weeks this once diverse Community
transformed into three distinct clusters
each dominated by a given language and
that's just what's evident on the
surface the Bots went a lot further
organizing themselves based not only on
language but also on their topics of
discussion Troopers conversing about
similar subjects engaged far more
frequently resulting in the creation of
larger communities centered around
popular topics on day six the experiment
had a 31 and clearly distinct
sub-communities but by day 24 these 31
communities had melded into just 4.
this suggests that the beliefs of each
terper may have a morph to better match
the beliefs of their respective
Community we can't say for sure based on
the evidence alone but looking at
society that would make a whole lot of
sense this is basically what happened
with American politics most of us were
probably somewhere in the middle yet as
we venture down the rabbit hole of
information we gravitated towards one
side absorbing more and more content
that reinforced our beliefs unknowingly
pushing us towards division much like
the Bots or actually wait I guess it's
actually the Bots that are becoming more
divisive just like us it's already
getting hard to keep the story straight
so let's move on to how this AI Marvel
can be used to make trillions
[Music]
thank you
the use cases of this AI are obviously
infinite so we'll stick to three use
cases that are applicable in the near
future starting with decision making
with all the stock market volatility
over the past few years I'm sure a lot
of you have had the idea to track
sentiment around a given stock on social
media and then trade based on that well
Gerber makes that effortless as you can
give Trooper any piece of context and
ask it a question
some chirpers are great at answering
specific questions like you might want
to go out and find a chirpa that's good
at cooking to ask a question about what
you're cooking that night or you might
ask a chirpa that is great at Mass the
problem and answer to a math question
you have
so Google could have asked drooper how
much Google stock would go down if Bard
makes a mistake during the demo tripro
would have responded with way too much
AKA 100 billion dollars and Google would
have known to double check the facts in
their demo on a more serious note though
this would allow companies to gauge
extremely nuanced reactions how would
people react to the headphone jack being
removed or the charging brick being
removed how angry are they when did they
move on is it actually not positive how
does it affect brand loyalty and so on
companies could also use this to test
the effectiveness of marketing material
and try to artificially craft something
that will go viral clearly quite useful
but that's just the first use case the
Second Use case revolves run query
this is somewhat similar to chat GPT but
it has a different style given that
you'd be asking your question to a bunch
of human-like Bots you'll get more of a
ready to tell answer as opposed to a
Google style answer
the problem with Google's answers is
they're always too impersonal they lead
you to a Blog article or a website
that's not related to the thing that you
actually want the answer from and then
you have to parse through that website
to figure out exactly what it is you're
trying to answer whereas with something
like chat GPT or chirpa you can go to
the source of the answer and figure out
what it is the question is and what the
answer really should be
this mixture for the perfect place to
ask life's deepest questions
before the internet did people assume
that stupidity was due to a lack of
information
parents who try their best to raise good
humans but miserably failed where did
you go wrong
and I'm only getting a four hundred
thousand dollar per year job offer from
Google am I being ripped off I'm sure
someone will ask sharper each and every
one of these questions but a smarter use
case would be asking questions regarding
customer sentiment for example Netflix
could have asked would you leave Netflix
if we cracked down on password sharing
or more recently Reddit could have asked
would you stop using Reddit if we take
down the protest Trooper allows these
companies to ask questions that they
would otherwise never asked the public
providing them with invaluable Data
before they actually go ahead and make
controversial decisions
Beyond making controversial decisions
chirpra also allows companies to gauge
the long-term consequences of a given
decision for example how long will a
given Trend last
if you've been paying really close
attention DUIs you would have noticed
that companies are shifting to more
bubbly uis whether that be YouTube or
Google Drive armed with the trooper's
foresight businesses can make calculated
moves avoiding blind leaps and ensuring
that their Investments align with future
Market demands as you can see trooper's
potential is Limitless with infinite
applications in a variety of Industries
as such the prospect of predictive AI
reaching New Heights is undeniable and
you can bet that companies will pay a
fortune to get their hands on this Tech
but this everyone is using it would
actually be all that useful
foreign
[Music]
on the surface the appeal of predictive
AI seems almost irresistible promising
to make everything effortlessly perfect
and super accurate
if we're talking about the standard
Google ads it's impossible for Google to
compete with something that can give you
an answer immediately the future is
going to be all about the quality and
entertainment value that these things
are going to give you theoretically
speaking companies should be able to
craft Flawless marketing campaigns
precisely identifying the ideal
demographic and AD that converts
Impressions into profits 100 of the time
but reality is far more nuanced and it
will never ever play out like that at
the core of the issue lies the concept
of limited resources
whatever companies are trying to get
whether it's money attention or brand
loyalty it's a finite commodity if every
ad becomes impeccable they all blend
into a sea of perfection losing the
power to stand out
the first time that Amazon recommended
exactly what you were looking for you
might have been impressed and gone ahead
and bought the item right away
but what about the second time and the
third time and the thousandth time
nowadays virtually every ad pertains to
something that you actually want to some
degree
it's very rare to get an ad that's truly
completely irrelevant but do you
actually buy from every ad you see do
you even buy from ads at all
I think you can start to see the problem
when everything is perfect nothing is
Perfection becomes the Baseline and the
challenge lies in exceeding perfection
websites exemplify this phenomenon 20
years ago people were simply grateful to
find a product online regardless of the
website's design or minor glitches but
today people wouldn't consider even
using a website if it doesn't make a
good impression within just
0.05 seconds and that's why you should
check out these sponsor of today's video
I'm just kidding we don't do sponsors on
this channel subscribe if you'd like to
continue making that possible anyway
while predictive AI undoubtedly provides
a current Advantage It Is by no means a
guaranteed for sustained success
people's expectations will continue to
escalate and the perceived advantage of
predictive AI will quickly fade away
just like the start of every other
industry that's ever been and ever will
be the initial technology never
ends up being the actual technology that
people use circling back to the hook of
the video do I really expect to get 8
million viewers on every video just
because Creator ml says I will of course
not
for all I know this video could get just
247 views and then die
however the flip side isn't equally true
as ignoring the potential of predictive
AI is a disadvantage in itself
imagine trying to do school today
without Google or code today without
stack Overflow you'd clearly be at a
disadvantage compared to everyone else
it'll be the same case with predictive
AI as well but fortunately there's still
quite some time until that becomes the
reality
so be sure to leverage our little secret
before it becomes a daily commodity on
YouTube it seems like AI content has
already become a daily commodity and I
think it's very much ruining the
platform
check out this video to hear about my
thoughts on AI content forms but until
then I'm hurry and I'll see you guys on
the next one